le rouge c'est celui de locre dont ce
peuple sans lui les himbas peuple
semi-nomade de namibie sont à l'honneur
de la semaine de la femme mme annick
watts chez les himbas c'est une société
matriarcale et l'héritage se transmet
par les femmes
c'est un peuple aussi qui qui lutte
vraiment pour sa survie
et enfin pour sa survie au sens être nos
logiques du terme c'est-à-dire
culturellement ils sont confrontés avec
la société moderne
le développement du tourisme en libye et
s'est gardé au maximum sa structure
familiale
plongée au coeur des traditions des
coutumes de ce peuple
cette exposition présentée pour la
première fois en 2008 est à l'initiative
d'une femme une française
solenn bardet ethnologue et géographe
elle avait 18 ans elle est partie seule
en afrique elle y est restée deux ans
auprès du peuple himba elle a même été
adoptés dont par par khadidja une femme
qui va devenir plus tard chefs de tribus
et depuis c'est elle qui est le porte
parole au niveau occidental et devenus
de ce peuple qui risque d'être en voie
de disparition
l'exposition est à découvrir au café de
l'estaminet jusqu'au dimanche 13 mars
une visite guidée est organisée le 9
mars prochain
de quoi plonger un peu plus en terre
inconnue